[Music]
god
thou hast allowed me to live till now i
thank thee and offer up my sufferings to
thee
and pray thee at the same time to take
me further into my protection
this and several other pious meditations
i had with god
and i considered my destiny although it
was never quiet the entire night and
though a new battle might have started
at any hour
none of all my miseries were so hard and
depressing
as the thought of my brothers sisters
and friends this thought was my greatest
pain
which i sought to repress with this hope
with god
everything is possible so i will depend
upon
his further help
in the month of january 1812 i was
recalled to the garrison of schondorf
from here the entire corpse marched
through the wurzburg district
where it was generally rumored that we
were going to spain and would embark
onto the baltic sea
although the outlook did not seem good i
and all the other soldiers were very
merry
always singing and dancing especially
since throughout the entire verzeberg
country
the quarters and eating and drinking
were very good particularly because of
the large supply of wine
so that everyone voluntarily had his
flask filled with wine and his pockets
with cookies
at the time of departure moreover the
beautiful villages on the main river
surrounded by vineyards fruit trees and
grain fields
put everyone in a happy mood we were
still very lively in these towns
singing and laughing cheerfully although
we could imagine
the unusual campaign before us but
everyone always believes in and
hopes for the best
this video is sponsored by the great
courses plus the premiere online
learning service
the great courses plus have been amazing
supporters of the work of me and my
brother for nearly three years now
and i've been using them non-stop during
that time it's an
amazing resource and if i need to brush
up my knowledge on any topic
no matter how huge they are who i turn
to
recently i have devoured their
foundation of western and eastern
civilization
lecture series incredibly detailed
explorations of pretty much everything
that modern society stands upon
from the first cities to the 20th
century fascinating
university level stuff ordered a very
reasonable subscription for what is
essentially a mounted of easily
digestible knowledge
i honestly can't recommend it highly
enough so check them out at
thegreatcoursesplus.com forward slash
voices
to get a free trial and show your
support for the channel too
i started with a free trial and never
looked back
[Music]
thanks
[Music]
from there the line of the march turned
towards frankfurt on the oda
where a halt was made here we were
quartered for three days and
by this time we had to be contented with
poor food and
regiment bread we had to drill even on
ascension day
so general hugo tried to remind his
royal highness the crown prince and not
to drill
saying that it was a holiday the crown
prince however
gave this answer i will do you a favour
general
and not arrest you do you think i don't
know what day it is
on corpus christi day we marched into
the city of torn
here for the first time we saw all the
corpse streaming together
all the gates were jammed and the
regiments had to wind through the
streets in a great throng
we still obtained quarters however we
had to prepare our own
food from our ration meat and bread the
meat came from the salted ice pits
there was a rumor that it had been
stored from the war of 1807.
the condition of the meat made the rumor
seem credible since the meat appeared
bluish black and was sharp as herrings
daily the hardships increased and there
was no hope of bread
my colonel spoke to us once and said
that we could hope for no more bread
until we crossed the enemy border
on june 25th the army went over the
bridges
we now believe that once in russia we
need do nothing but forage which
however proved to be an illusion
[Applause]
the towns were already stripped before
we could enter and so were all the
villagers
here and there a hog ran around and was
beaten with clubs chopped with sabers
and stabbed with bayonets
several times i succeeded in cutting off
something but i had to chew it and eat
it
uncooked since my hunger could not wait
for a chance to boil the meat
during the third night a halt was made
in a field which was trampled
into a swamp here we were ordered to
camp and to make fires
since neither village nor forest could
be seen and the rain
continued without end well you can
imagine in
what a half numbed condition everyone
stood here what could we do
there was nothing that we could do but
stack the rifles in pyramids
and keep moving in order not to freeze
meanwhile a cellar full of brandy had
been discovered i too pushed myself into
the cellar
and filled my field flask i returned to
the shelter with this
and drank it without even any bread then
by noon
i noticed that half the men had stayed
back and several
had suffocated in the swamp the brandy
helped
but many a man drank himself to death
because he would become numbed
and would freeze on account of the wet
and cold
it then happened to be good weather but
in order to obtain
water for drinking and cooking holes
were dug into the swamps three feet deep
in which the water collected the water
was
very warm however and was reddish brown
with millions of little red worms
so that it had to be bound in linen and
sucked through with the mouth
this was of course a hardship for any
man
and particularly for us living as we
were
the march was kept up day and night
one man after another stretched himself
half dead upon the ground most of them
died a few hours later
several however suddenly fell to the
ground
dead the chief cause of this was thirst
for in most districts there was no water
fit for drinking
so the men had to drink out of the
ditches in which were dead horses
and dead men
on august 16 we came towards the city of
smolensk
here my company had only 25
fit men on the morning of august 17th
every regiment was set in motion and all
advanced in columns against the russians
here every regiment without exception
was under fire again
and again the troops attempted assaults
but because of the greater number of
russians
we were forced back every time on this
day
since their heavy artillery stood on the
heights and could hit everything
finally by night we had made good our
position on the heights overlooking the
city
and the battle was discontinued
that night the thought of the coming day
alternated with fitful sleep
and in fantasy the many dead men and
horses came as a world of spirits
before the last judgment
as soon as the day broke we marched
against the city
the river was crossed below the city the
suburbs on the northern side were
stormed
set on fire and burnt up my company's
doctor
named stauble had his arm shot away in
crossing the stream
and he died afterwards no longer could i
pay any attention to my comrades and
therefore
knew not in what way they perished or
were lost
everyone fired and struck at the enemy
in wild madness and no one could tell
whether he was in front in the middle or
behind the center of the army
on august the 19th the entire army moved
forward and pursued the russians with
all speed
from smelensk to mashaysk the war
displayed its horrible work of
destruction
all the roads fields and woods lay as
though sown with people
horses wagons burned villages and cities
everything looked like the complete ruin
of all that lived
in particular we saw ten dead russians
to one of our men although every day our
numbers fell off considerably
the cities in the meantime were dora
gaboush semlevo
viasma and gashatsk the march up to
there
as far as it was a march is
indescribable and
inconceivable for people who have not
seen anything of it
the very great heat the dust which was
like a thick fog
the closed line of marching columns and
the putrid water from holes
filled with dead people and cattle
brought everyone
close to death and eye pains fatigue
thirst and hunger
tormented everybody god how i remembered
the bread and beer which i'd enjoyed at
home with such indifferent pleasure
how gladly would i renounce my whole
life the warm
food so common at home if i only did not
lack
good bread and beer now wherever i
looked i saw the soldiers with dead
half-desperate faces
many cried out in despair if only my
mother had not borne me
some demoralized men even cursed their
parents
and their birth
on the route to moscow on september the
7th every corpse was assigned its place
and the signal to attack was given
[Music]
like thunderbolts the firing began both
against and from the enemy
this beautiful grain region without
woods and villages
could now be compared to a cleared
forest
a few trunks here and there looking grey
and white
within a space an hour and a half long
and wide the ground
was covered with people and animals we
moved forward and camped by a forest on
a height facing moscow
it was full of green trees now we
traveled with somewhat higher hopes
towards moscow
yet with the expectation that we should
clash again with the russians
but the russians thought themselves too
weak
and went through the city setting fire
to many parts
and the inhabitants were abandoned
on the march into the city or rather on
the march towards it
from a hill in a forest an hour and a
half away we saw
the huge city lying before us
clouds of fire red smoke great gilded
crosses of the church towers glittered
shimmered and billowed up towards us
from the city
this holy city was like the description
of the city of jerusalem
over which our savior wept it even
resembled the horror
and the wasting according to the gospel
[Music]
after a few hours walking we went past
the palace kremlin
in moscow one could find and buy
provisions for each soldier was now
citizen merchant innkeeper and baker of
moscow
whoever could find nothing could buy
something and vegetables in sufficient
quantity stood in the fields it was
still good weather and one could sleep
warm enough
under a coat at night after we had been
citizens of moscow for four weeks
we lost our burger rights again napoleon
refused the peace treaty proposed to him
and the army which had advanced some 30
hours further on
had to retreat because the russian army
stationed in moldavia was approaching
now was october the 17th and napoleon
held an army review
and announced the departure for october
18th early in the morning at 3 o'clock
with the warning that whoever should
delay one hour would fall
into the hands of the enemies all beer
brandy etc was abandoned
and whatever was still intact was
ordered to be burnt napoleon himself had
the kremlin undermined
and blown up then everyone packed up and
the enemy
attacked us the decision was soon to the
advantage of the russians
and all ran in a crowded retreat the
army moving towards heluga
with the cossacks in front and behind us
those who were too weak to carry their
weapons or knapsacks
threw them away and all looked like a
crowd of gypsies
the fighting the shrieking the firing of
large and small guns hunger and thirst
and all conceivable
torments increased the never-ending
confusion
indeed even the lice seemed to seek
supremacy
for their number on both officers and
privates was in the thousands
in these days it snowed for the first
time and the snow
remained the cold arrived at the same
time too
and the freezing of the people
multiplied the number of the dead
no one could walk 50 paces without
seeing men stretched out half
or completely dead we arrived at
smolensk on november 12th having made
from moscow to that city
26 days and nights of travel without
pausing a day
here we settled down and had to camp for
two days
every night the fires for warming could
be seen over a region
four hours long and wide reddening the
sky like red cloth
again and again people died and
sometimes froze to death
these were people who pressed towards
the fire but were seldom permitted to
get there
so they died away from the fire and very
often
they were even converted into cushions
in order that the living would not have
to sit
on the snow
when we came near the beresina river
there was a place where napoleon ordered
the pack horses to be unharnessed
and where he ate he watched his army
pass by in the most
wretched condition what he may have felt
in his heart is impossible to surmise
his outward appearance seemed
indifferent and unconcerned over the
wretchedness of his soldiers
only ambition and lost honor may have
made themselves felt in his heart
in this region we came to a half-burned
village away from the road
in which a cellar was found under a
mansion we sought for potatoes and
and i also pressed down the broad
stairway although the cellar was already
half filled with people
when i was at the bottom of the steps
the screaming began
under my feet everyone crowded in and no
one could get out
here people were trampled to death and
suffocated those who wanted to stoop
down for something were bowled over by
those standing
and had to be stepped upon in spite of
the murderous shrieking and frightful
groaning the pressure from outside
increased
the poor deathly weak men who fell had
to lie there
until dead under the feet of their own
comrades
i thought of my friends at home and
compared my misery and approaching end
with my former life of plenty
i remember the common saying at home a
campaign is always made out to be worse
than it was
with this common notion i consoled
myself thinking
it's well that you my beloved kindred
and friends
know nothing of my condition for it
would only cause you pain and it would
be of no use
to me i gave up pushing into the cellar
and i thought in cold fear how will i
get out again
i pressed flat against the wall so it
afforded me shelter and pushed myself
vigorously little by little up the
stairs
this was almost impossible with others
treading on my long coat
finally i came to ordersburg and for the
first time was given regular
quarters from this city i went on to
moava
and at that place received quarters
again it was just christmas eve
a date i would not have known if i had
not learnt it from the landlord
the washing of my hands and face
proceeded very slowly
because the crusts on my hands ears and
nose had grown like
fur lark with cracks and cold black
scales
i washed then for an hour with hot water
and soap however i felt i had only
become
somewhat smoother and lighter but i
could not notice any removal of the
blackness
and the scales
finally on february the 24th 1813
i arrived at elvangan my convoy to here
had left behind 100 dead out of 175
men all at once i saw my brother-in-law
and my brother
they would not have recognized me of
course as i looked then but i cooled
thrust out my hand
and greeted them they jumped into the
air for joy and pressed my hands
and our hearts alone could feel for we
could not speak
oh that all people might know how high
the love of friends and relatives can
mount through such a meeting
one feels in it heavenly joy the
all-wise providence of god
and at the same time the miracle of
nature
[Music]